this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
would you like to simplify your life yes
[Laughter]
oh wait is that a rhetorical question
these backdrops in here is just too much
there's three colors
how can i cope i want my life to be
monochrome
you know the gal we're working with
beulah beulah anne you can follow her on
instagram at beulah
she's doing the set design for our new
studio which is hiding behind this
beautiful wrapping paper that's behind
us we're gonna unveil a gift
to you really soon and um yeah
she texted me the other day she said my
soul is black and white and beige
because i'm constantly asking her like
how do we inject some personality
because if it's just me and you this
place is going to look like an insane
asylum
right white walls or just paint the
floor white yeah i'll put you in a
straight jacket
padded walls yeah i mean they're already
kind of padded for sound
you're right yeah they are it doesn't oh
my gosh
i know you could record an insane asylum
genius
anyway if you're looking to simplify
your life that's often why people
tune in to this podcast especially this
public version
of the podcast the minimal episodes a
few minimal
a few minimalism rules might
help now here's the thing about rules
rules help us to
a point but
they help as long as they don't get in
the way if they become too
constrictive or restrictive
then they don't serve us they don't add
value now ryan and i we had a new book
just come out last week called love
people use things
because the opposite never works and in
that book there are 16 rules for living
with less these are 16 rules which you
can download for free on our website by
the
way
the minimalists.com rulebook there's
actually an expanded version
of each of those rules there but i
wanted to talk about
some of these rules and how they might
apply to some of the questions that
people are asking
but before we do that the thing the one
of the biggest comments i'm getting
about this new book ryan is people
they're really enjoying the switch in
tone between my sections and your
section so
the the book is about these seven
essential relationships in our life it
starts with our relationship with stuff
and then it talks about
truth and self and values money
creativity
people and at the end of each chapter
you finish with a coda
yeah and so it's really five questions
about
that chapter so i want to start today by
talking since we're talking about stuff
five questions for stuff and then we
have the do's and don'ts
in each chapter as well the do's and
don'ts of
stuff so maybe ryan if we turn to page
70 here
we could talk about this coda for stuff
cool let's do it alright so this is the
very first coda after the
at the end of the chapter stuff howdy
ryan nicodemus here
i'll be here at these end chapter
sections throughout the book to help you
reflect
on what you've read and consider how you
can implement
the lessons learned from each chapter
questions about stuff first answer the
following questions
be honest be considerate be rigorous
your future self will appreciate your
hard work contemplation
and candor question number one
how much is enough for you and your
household be specific
amount of bedrooms televisions coats in
the closet
think closely about the things that
actually add
value to your life let's pause right
there real quick
so what i like about these questions is
they're not too
prescriptive in fact they're they're
highly individual
yeah and that's what i think is so
important about these
rules they're not stuffy they're they're
not well here's the
seven things you must do in order to be
a minimalist yeah
here is our ideology our dogma
we want to avoid all of that and if we
avoid that
then some of these rules some of these
questions they can actually
help us identify like with this question
for example what is enough for you or
your household or the other people in
your household and also keeping in mind
what is enough for you might be
different from what is enough for your
spouse
or your daughter yeah or your grandma
you know the whole point
for me uh when i was writing these codas
was really
to help people set up their own
boundaries i mean yes we have the the
rules
uh we have the rule book but really i
don't really
i don't like the word rules i i prefer
boundaries because that's really what it
is
there is and everybody's boundaries are
going to be a little bit different right
but yeah like that first question
i was thinking to myself how can i help
someone get clear on what their
boundaries
might be and i think that's a very
appropriate question like hey what's
enough let's start there and then we
could build around that
rather than looking at your life or my
life or someone else's life and saying
oh that's how they live their life those
are the boundaries that i want
i mean could that work yeah maybe but
but there's a there's a
little bit more of a i don't know
personalized way you can approach it i
think
i like to think of it as recipe in a way
as well so i think boundaries works
really well
i also think recipe works and so the
reason we use rules that's that's the
term
people are familiar with but then they
get in here and they're like oh these
are so malleable
right just like a recipe is if you have
this recipe for this
amazing curry but you don't like onions
simply leave the onions
out of the curry or what if you really
like onions and it doesn't have onions
in the recipe
well then you can put onions whatever
you want including your breakfast cereal
if you enjoy it right we're not telling
you to do anything specific
ryan let's read one more question we
don't want to have to go through all of
them here
but this uh the second one i thought was
was
important yeah what are you afraid to
let go of
why i think i think we're all
probably guilty of afraid to let go of
something in our lives right
uh i think that this journey over the
last 12 years has really helped me to
let go of
99 of my expectations or or
has helped me uh to cling less to things
but i mean there certainly are things
that
um yeah like my relationship with mariah
i would be scared to let go of that
sure but why right well there's there's
a deeper why there
that uh that i really hope people can
get to and what i love about that is
by articulating it and so i often
encourage people to say this out loud
because with the mariah thing you can
unders you say it
out loud it's easier to understand the
implications of that
but if you say i'm afraid to let go of
this shirt i haven't worn in four years
as soon as you say something like that
out loud it becomes absurd yeah
and that absurdity quite often magnifies
our need or sometimes even our desire to
let go
right so throughout the book we have
these uh the questions that you ask here
but in the quotas as well
you have the do's and don'ts maybe we
could read if a do
one of the dues do you have five dudes
five don'ts
with respect to stuff sure let's pick
one of these this is page 72 for those
of you following along at home
okay um let's oh you know what let's go
with the second
dose of stuff establish your rules
using the minimalist rules for living
with less
introduced in this chapter identify the
rules you will start using today
if a particular rule doesn't fit your
situation feel free to modify it or
create your own so
this is specific i said start using it
today because for someone who wants to
make a shift with how they approach
their stuff or whatever it is i mean
there is something
that one can do right now absolutely to
start
living a little bit of a different life
quite often we feel like we have no
momentum
right and so that's we're steeped in all
of this stuff we're steeped in
consumerism we're steeped in impulse and
desire
and yearning and craving and all of that
is so overwhelming
and so the fear question you asked
earlier what are you afraid of
sometimes you know fear always says
something about the future right you're
never afraid of something that happened
in the past unless you're
very neurotic um but but which
uh you know as a neurotic myself i can
identify with it but really
fear says something worry says something
anxiety says something
about an imagined future yeah and
the future doesn't exist the past
doesn't exist the past exists only in
the present as memories of the past
the future exists only as projections as
thoughts of what might happen in the
future
and so excitement is fear but the
opposite
it's the obverse side of that coin in a
way i'm excited about what might
happen yeah whereas joy peace
contentment happiness freedom any of
these words that can often mean the same
thing
happens here and now it is not pursued
happiness is not in the future it's not
in the past
and what i like about what you have here
about the today thing
is simplifying is not tomorrow we called
our last film
less is now not less is tomorrow right
less is next week
right less is now now is the time
for less so you have these five dues
five don'ts at the end of each chapter
maybe we talk about one of the
the don'ts here i think this first one
is pretty important for people to
understand especially uh
those who are super anxious about the
way they're living
right now in the moment overwhelmed yeah
so the the first don't here is this
don't expect to get rid of everything at
once took
time to acquire those possessions and it
will take time
to let go i am so guilty of like wanting
to change something in my life
and i make all these or i set all these
expectations
for the immediate future whether it's
that day or
the next day or that week and the
problem is is i set up way too many
expectations
right and when i do that uh as soon as i
don't meet one of those i start to just
let everything go oh well you know i
i said i was gonna work out every single
day this week but i missed one day
so man i just ruined the whole thing i
might as well just not work out i mean
it's easier for us to
talk ourselves out of something when we
feel like we're failing constantly so
that's right setting the bar
you know not low but but just raising
your standard a little bit maybe that's
a better way of saying it raising your
standard just a little bit is going to
help you
start to build that momentum get to that
next step
but if you read this book and you're
like oh by the end of the week i'm going
to
declutter all my 300 000 items yes which
is probably not a proper expectation
it took you 30 years ryan to accumulate
all of those things and to
think you can get rid of it overnight
and also get rid of the attachment to
those things not just the things because
yeah you could
there's a story of the kirkin dolls in
this book uh
jason and jennifer kirkendall who lost
everything i'm not gonna i don't wanna
spoil the story because it's such a good
story
it might be one of my favorites in in
the book if not my favorite
but they lost everything but they had
already gotten rid of the attachment
and they had they lost everything a year
earlier or even a month earlier for them
it would have been devastating yeah and
so you don't want to devastate yourself
the same like when i when i
used to be obese right and
i wanted to i'm gonna i'm gonna fix my
diet it's all gonna be perfect and i'm
gonna
work out really hard every day and so
what do i do i go to the gym the first
day
and wear myself out right i'm so
exhausted i'm
sore the next day i don't want to do
anything yeah and you have to be careful
with that as well
when it comes to your stuff i get you
you get excited you have this momentum
but you can burn yourself out if you try
to apply
all the rules and everything all at
once it's like becoming clear to me why
i chose to do the packing party
right because it was such an extreme let
me
get everything out of sight uh but also
i could have put everything back if i
wanted to yeah you had a safety net
in a way right yeah well so throughout
the book we have these 16 rules for
living with less ryan do you have a
favorite rule and they're rather they're
peppered throughout the book so there's
four they're in the early stuff chapter
there's two rules throughout the book
and they sort of coincide beautifully
with what we're talking about in each
chapter yeah oh man for me
it's got to be the spontaneous
combustion role okay so i just remember
kind of coming up with that rule on the
fly with uh a lady who was
at our event and she asked the question
she was like you know my mom
like when i was 16 years old she made me
this quilt
and she made it out of a fabric that she
had printed memories on with me
with me and my friends sports memories
family memories and like there's this
quilt
of of basically pictures of of her uh
teenage years on it right
and she was like i don't use it anymore
like it's a little gaudy like it just
sits in my closet and
i don't know what to do with it i try to
donate it but you know no one's gonna
want this quilt
which i would posit that you know
there's somebody out there who would
like see that at goodwill with these
random memories on it and they would
chris bailey who we just had on the
podcast yeah exactly
100 so um if anything that is that's
that's also a lesson in
let the donation place decide whether or
not it could be given away yeah
don't don't uh don't just decide that on
your own um so
i could just see the pain like she was
going through like this this clinging
this attachment
and i just asked her i'm like well what
would you do right now you got home
and you found out that that thing had
spontaneously combusted in your closet
how would you feel
and she was like oh i feel relieved yes
i'm like well that's
that's a symptom it's a sign that it's
okay to let that go
and i think with all of our things
especially when you get away from the
non-sentimental items
like that the replaceable things because
clear if that thing spontaneously
combusted
she couldn't replace i mean she could
replace it with another quilt
sure right functionally replace it yes
but many of the things we have in our
home asking that question
what i feel relieved and the question
you asked even before that is
would i replace it and so like for
example this coffee mug that i'm holding
up here if you're watching this on
youtube
let me know if you enjoy this coffee mug
in the comments like and subscribe just
kidding you can do whatever you want i
don't really care but make sure you're
watching it in what
1080 yeah yeah so instead of liking and
subscribing
just go down to the bottom and make sure
it's set to 1080p none of the 720 crap
we're not gonna have it isn't that right
danny am i right we have danny martinez
in the studio today he's helping out
with some audio video stuff
with us um he's next here to jordan know
more podcast sean
and um so uh what was i doing
yeah coffee cup yes if this thing
spontaneously combusted
i wouldn't lose any sleep over it i
would i'd go on to what's the company
called
not neutral and i would buy one more
coffee mug
because i have just enough coffee mugs
and if this broke which has happened
before we've broken these
in the studio i would not feel relieved
i but i would simply replace it and
that's great but
if there's something else where i'm like
you know what that sound panel over
there which we're actually selling this
week
if it's spontaneously combusted i would
not replace it so what does that mean
well i need to get rid of it then yeah
so we are selling it in fact
and so we have old sound panels in here
from our from our old studio until
some of the new stuff comes in anyway my
favorite rule
it's so hard to pick just one it's
probably spontaneous combustion rules
because
the utility of that it's simple it
really is gets right to the point
so i'm gonna pick another rule because
so that one helps you deal with the
stuff that you have in
your life what what rule really helps
with staving off
impulse and for me that's the wait for
it rule is also known as the 30 30 rule
and so it's a good one you're all good
really yeah i mean
yeah we we've had way more than than 16
these are our favorites right so we
collected them all into into one place
anyway the wait for it rule is hey 30
30 hours so if it costs more than 30
dollars
i give myself 30 hours that means
there's no one-click purchase
there's no oh yeah but i you know what i
didn't think about this i do want to buy
that widget while i'm at the store okay
great i can come back tomorrow
it's adding a little bit of
inconvenience but not really
inconvenience a little bit of friction
because what's happened in the modern
world of consumerism we've removed all
the friction
well what happens you remove all the
friction you're on an ice rink and you
slide
everywhere and that's what consumerism
is doing to us now we're pinging
careening from wall to wall to wall
buying this buying that because
companies are making us feel
inadequate so i think that's probably my
favorite rule but i'm interested to hear
what your
favorite rule is or if you have one that
we're not talking about today that's not
part of the 16 rules
let us know in the youtube comments i'm
always looking for
new rules in fact on the maximal episode
this week ryan so on the minimal episode
which you're listening to right now
we're talking about minimalism rules but
on the maximal this week
we're going to talk about the best rules
created by our listeners we collected
some of our favorites that aren't part
of the 16
rules or some of them almost feel like
offshoots of the 16
rules for living with less anyway if you
are a patreon support and you haven't
already listened
last week we did a three plus hour
extravaganza
on the private podcast with our good
friend tk coleman mvp
man i can tell you this it's my favorite
episode we've ever done
really yeah it was called the symbiosis
of love and we've recorded hundreds and
hundreds of episodes
that three-hour conversation it could
because it could have gone eight hours
we just kept going we were answering
questions the
all three of us were just on at the time
in a way where
this conversation was flowing and i
really enjoyed it
people i mean the response over on
patreon has been amazing for the tk
episode awesome
so yeah it was good i enjoyed it too
that was his ninth appearance uh you can
find that on our private podcast
patreon.com
the minimalist every week we do a long
form
maximal episode over there we also do a
bunch of other stuff live events
etc etc but the main thing is the
minimalist
private podcast joining our patreon is
easier than ever right now so you can
try it for a
month i think you'll enjoy it we have a
question here from anna
in eureka california i was calling
because recently
in my journey towards minimalism i've
come against
a fear a fear of using things that i
love
and wearing them out or breaking them
those pair of pants that look great on
me but i don't want to wear them
in less special occasion i've started
wearing them
three to five times a week but i know
that in some
future time i'm going to have to replace
them
or they will get stained and worn out
can you address that fear
of that many people may have so
anna i noticed a few things in your
question that i just want to tweeze
out because i don't want to be pedantic
in terms of language but i
think often the language we use around
something
forces us to accidentally cling to
certain ideas
narratives or even physical things
without us
realizing it so the first thing that she
talked about ryan is her journey
minimalism well minimalism is not a
destination right minimalism is
the path and so it's a tool that we use
to simplify our lives so
quite often one of the the biggest
misconceptions about minimalism is that
i'm going to get
there there's nowhere to get yeah a
carpenter uses a hammer
the point of his or her job is not to
get
the hammer it's to build
something meaningful yeah that's what we
want to do with minimal is we want to
build
a meaningful life now ryan you probably
noticed she talked about having some
things that she loves
yeah and of course in the book we we
talk about this and a lot of people use
things about how we have
this language problem right
and how that if we if we lo
i love you ryan but then i also love
this coffee that's in front of me
right now we can make a distinction we
talked about this already there's an
extreme like i really like this coffee
yeah and i love you i don't like you
very much but i love you ryan
oh i like you oh thanks
and and so i think we have to be careful
when we talk about the loving of things
because i know what you mean you know
what you mean it's just an extreme like
but sometimes we can get confused when
so instead of saying
i love something i can say this is my
favorite coffee mug
now it places in its actual context it
still gives us a place of importance
it's more important than other coffee
mugs to me
but at the same time i don't love it i'd
be perfectly fine
without it right and so just simply
saying that and the last thing i'll say
here is the
fear of breaking those things or wearing
them out well you don't have to fear
that it's going to happen
yes right it's like death you could fear
death until you die but it's still going
to happen whether or not you fear it
you hear the story of the guy who said
yeah worrying is very helpful to me
because every time i worry about
something it doesn't happen
it's pretty funny and and so we can
worry about the things that are never
going to happen but then also
we can worry about the things that we
know are going to happen these are my
favorite pair of jeans that i'm wearing
right now i don't love them but they're
my favorite
yeah but they're really starting to wear
out i've got a hole in the crotch right
now thankfully i wear
same color underwear as these black
jeans so you can't tell so very soon i'm
going to have to replace them
but as a minimalist all of my things
are my favorite things otherwise i've
let them go yeah oh man i what i hear
with anna's question is she's living in
the future
and she's you know worrying about the
future and
man what came to mind for me was
these pair of pants i have one right now
okay yes i bought a pair
really enjoyed them lots of compliments
on them
and then like i ripped the really tight
yoga pants that's right exactly
they really accentuate his glutes
everyone has good glutes and yoga pants
no so i i i'd rip them or something and
i had to
i like had to replace them and i went to
go replace them and they were gone
and i was like oh no they got
discontinued and i realized i got
discontinued because of how easily they
rip
actually so i went to ebay and i
found uh i found a two pair and i was
like you know what like i really
enjoy these pants i'm going to i'm going
to get
two of the same pair so that but so
that'll make them last longer
but i've also come to the realization
that you what you just said like hey
they're all going to wear out at a
certain point so
instead of worrying about uh instead of
worrying about these pants
um you know ripping and being ruined
really i just kind of appreciate like oh
wow like they're in style right now
they look good i can alternate these two
pair right and
uh you know yeah i didn't buy like 10
pairs of them i didn't use it as that
excuse
me sure all right i didn't yeah i didn't
use these
getting destroyed as an excuse to go by
10 pair so yeah anna
um man this sounds like there's to me
sounds like there's something
like maybe a little deeper going on yes
what are you scared of what
what are you really scared of because
ultimately you could wear
uh plain black pants and a plain black
shirt
and you're still gonna be okay yes yeah
like you are complete how you are anna
there's not a pair of
pants or whatever an item that's going
to make you any more whole
so maybe an exercise and i remember i
did this back in 2011 and wrote about it
someone asked me a journalist asked me
what
is your what are your three favorite
items right
and i had to sort of step back and i
found my favorite i'm like ah
this is kind of silly like that's not
the point of minimalism but okay i get
it
so my here's my favorite shirt here my
favorite shoes
and here is my favorite pair of pants
and i got the thinking
why are these my favorite and i had an
attachment they were my favorites back
from the corporate days because it was
just the same year i left the corporate
world right yeah in 2011.
and so i was clinging to part of the
past there was something deeper than the
things
and so i said you know what these are my
favorites but they're only my favorites
because i said they're my favorites i've
allocated that
favoritism toward them right and so i'm
going
to see if i can let even my favorite
things go
see how it feels and guess what happened
new favorites emerged yeah
and by the way if i still was clinging
to the that old pair of pants and shirt
or
shoes from back then they'd be destroyed
by now
a decade plus later right yeah and so
if i was just clinging i'm going to be
clinging to something that is
disintegrating
yeah but isn't that the metaphor for all
clinging on a long enough timeline
yeah 100 man yeah i i really have
practiced over the last 12 years of
letting go so like right now if these
pants
spontaneously combusted and right stop
drop and roll yeah right exactly i'd be
like oh man like there would be like a
twinge of like oh man like now i had the
you know the work of like going out
trying on some new pants right i don't
know what it is maybe just because i'm
40 and i'm getting older i'm like i
don't want to go
and shop for pants yeah it sucks driving
to the beverly center right exactly but
ultimately i
also understand that's like what you
just said something else
will step up and become my new favorite
pair of pants
so uh yeah anna practice letting go with
other things in your life
and see if that can translate or
transfer over to the items that you're
really clinging to right now
we also did an episode about trendy
fashion we'll put a link to that
in the show notes by the way and i'm
gonna send you a copy of our new book
it's called love people
use things because the opposite never
works if you enjoy our podcast you'll
really like the audiobook version ryan
and i spent
two weeks in the studio recording this
audiobook and it sounds
great or if you want the book book or
the ebook version those are available
we'll send those to
you as well all right yesterday we we
drove around los angeles signing copies
of the book so yeah if you are in la
county
the barnes and noble at the grove still
have some copies
but then we went to a bunch of indie
book shops so skylight cavaliers and
larchmont
we went to diesel over in brentwood we
went to
romans in pasadena yeah we went to a
couple of them yeah book soup
and i feel like there's one or two
others out there
but uh yeah if you're in the la county
you want to grab an autographed copy of
love people use things you can do that
or
you can find it at your local bookstore
or your local library
nora from facebook has a comment about
some of her favorite rules
my favorite rule is turning all the
hangers in the closet backwards on
january 1st
replacing them correctly as items are
used through the year
anything still backwards on december
31st goes
this sounds to me like a a visual
version
of our seasonality rule aka the 90 90
rule yeah
this is 365 for her or really it's like
six months six months whatever but
it is you know so the 90-90 rules
basically have i used this in the last
90 days if not am i going to use it in
the next 90 days so it covers
all seasons and if not i give myself
permission
to let go and what nora is doing she's
creating a visual representation
of it because if sometimes we have all
these clothes and i can't really
remember the last time i wore that well
now nora knows well i haven't worn it
since january 1st and you could
attenuate this if you want to get more
aggressive
you don't have to do it all in one day
but what if you did it in one month or
three months or six months
if you feel like that is more
appropriate for you
jensen had something in that same vein
you want to read his comment
i have the exact amount of hangers
needed for every item of clothing i have
so that if i want another article of
clothing i have to donate or sell at
least one
item to accommodate it this reminds me
of the one
in 10 out rule so this
we came with this rule because like bars
nightclubs military establishments etc
if they reach a fire code capacity they
do one in one l so you have to wait till
someone leaves before someone can go in
and
we all saw this during the pandemic
where grocery store lines
you had to wait for one person to come
out so you could go in one in one out
with our stuff if we're looking to let
go now this isn't sustainable
in perpetuity because eventually you'd
end up with negative number of items
right but the one in 10 out rule as
you're letting go is hey if i bring one
thing into my life
i'm going to give up 10 of a like
or a like-for-like item so if i have
clothing or buy one piece of clothing
and i'm trying to get rid of some
clothing now
i have to get rid of 10 items it's a
great excuse to find 10 things to get
rid of
if you want to buy a new kitchen utensil
great you have to let go of 10 things in
the kitchen right
and you can do that anywhere else in
your house and
and so you can do that with the the
hangers as well you can do one in one
out it's again a visual
representation let us know if you have
some of your favorite rules i call them
the 17th rule
your rule your favorite rule is the 17th
rule let us know in
the youtube comments ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it is time
for our lightning round where we answer
your text messages
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones we even respond to some people
personally or
we respond to you on the air now during
the lightning round so ryan and i do our
best to answer every question
with a short shareable less than 140
character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maximums in one place thanks to our good
friend jessica lynne williams those are
over at minimalmaxims.com
all right we got a question from emery's
how do you develop
and maintain the discipline needed to
stick to your minimalism rules or other
habits
you're trying to establish i'll be on a
roll for a week
and slip up for one day and struggle to
get back on the horse for months after
it's so frustrating that is frustrating
i totally get it this is
back to the gym analogy i did earlier or
for me the food analogy was even bigger
when i was obese you know i weighed 70
80 maybe even 90 pounds more than i
weighed now
and yeah it was all third chin and
muffin top really
i i strangely still had these same
skinny legs
at 240 pounds anyway
um i would change what i ate but i was
so militant about it i didn't really
understand
i didn't understand what i was doing i
just understood the actions i wanted to
take
yeah but i didn't have a deep enough why
so do you have something pithy for us
then i can append it with my pithy
answer
yeah my pithy answer is this habit
changes don't work as well as lifestyle
changes
amen so you know it's easier to fast
than it is to diet
and what i mean by that is like a diet
that is a habit that someone wants to
bring in but it's a temporary thing and
that's
really how a lot of our habits start or
or our desired habits is we have this
outcome that we want
and then we're like okay uh once i i'm
gonna start doing x y and z to get there
but once you get there the habits start
to fall off
where really looking at something as a
lifestyle change is going to be so much
more impactful
than just trying to get you know
you try to get you know yourself a year
in the future 50 pounds less like that
is
right that's a temporary mindset um but
the one thing i will say emery's
is just don't give up like that's i mean
that's really like the one thing i want
to encourage you to do
is yeah you're going to screw up you're
not going to be perfect
but don't give up don't use this
attitude as a reason to
to give up um josh you talked earlier
about the language you we use
and the language that emory is using
here is it's a little disempowering
yeah so so what the question asked then
is what is the empowering language i
could use i don't i don't want you to do
anything inauthentic
right it's simply a reframing right we
can talk about criticism or we can talk
about opportunities
are they the same thing yeah
fundamentally but one
points toward where i can go
right an opportunity for growth one
points at the past and what i did wrong
it's the same
thing we're just looking at it from a
different vantage point right yeah
we hear something pithy for you and then
i'd love to unpack it with you ryan
once you understand the why the how
takes care of itself so right now you're
understanding the how
yeah it's the same thing with
decluttering you don't need more
decluttering tips from me and ryan you
don't even need
rules they can be helpful as boundaries
as ryan
said but ultimately what you need is a
deeper understanding of why it's the
reason we start
our last film less is now on netflix we
started that film with that question
how might your life be better with
less anthony demello would say that
any time you're unhappy it's because
you're adding anything additive
creates discontent for us and so
we're for simply just adding habits or
adding
changes to our life thinking we're going
to be happy isn't that the same thing as
buying the widget
buying the car buying the house thinking
that's going to make me happy
yeah those things can only augment your
life at best
they can never make you happy happiness
is always uncovered and it is blocked
by addition it is uncovered by
subtraction there's something pithy
there as well podcast sean you can
you can tweet that ryan we've got so
much more to talk about today but first
what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out
hi my name is candace and i'm calling
from ottawa canada and i have a tip for
the girl on your non-line
um podcast where she was talking about
how she liked candles
um i am a minimalist and also oh wait i
live waist free so what i do is um
i get a candle without any packaging
from you know i'm really lucky because i
have a friend who makes them
but you can probably get them from any
craft store
and then let it burn whenever you you
when you like it put the
excess wax that falls off um
into a mason jar and then when that
candle is done what i do
is save all the wax and microwave it
and melt all the wax and then get a new
wick from a craft store and the candle
lives on forever so you never have to
buy a new candle
and at the same time your you still get
to enjoy the pleasures
of having candles and it's worked really
well saved me a ton of money and saved
a lot of plastic for the environment
my name is scott wood i live in phoenix
arizona
i wanted to make a comment about a lot
of people who struggle with family
members who are not minimalist
i'm new to the minimalism process
and how i got my wife into it was to
to discuss each purchase a month ahead
of time
we have a chalkboard it's actually
chalkboard paint on the wall
and we write down the purchases that we
want to buy so if we're walking through
a grocery store or we're walking through
um a mall which we really don't do
anymore but just for example
and my wife says oh i really want that
book or i really want that blouse
or i say that we go ahead and we write
it in the chocolate when we get home
so it's not a it's not an impulse
purchase
and we wait till the end of the month
and the reason we wait in the month is
i'm in sales
my um my large commission check comes in
at the end of the month
and my wife is in sales as well so we
have the means
without going into debt without using a
credit card to purchase
those items i actually put your book on
my list at one point in time and had to
wait 30 days to get it so i could read
it
um but it takes away a lot of things so
i may put
seven items on there the first month and
by the end of the month i only bought
one or two
the next month i may have three or four
items in the month i may have bought one
the third month i had nothing on the
list and i was kind of disappointed
but at the same time there's a little
bit of excitement because what it did is
it whittled down my
my impulse needs to buy and i started
looking at things differently
um but my wife who wasn't sure whether
she wanted to be involved with
minimalism or my four kids who also use
this lift system
had begun to see the the benefits of it
and we discussed a lot of pleasure
versus
happiness because you get these things
and they give you temporary pleasure
or a spike of joy but then you get home
and you rip them open
or you you you you experience the book
or you
you play with the item and 20 30 minutes
sometimes a week later
the item is just untouched again so now
there
there seems to be a lot more deliberate
process in which
we buy things all right ryan we got a
bunch more to talk about this week this
thursday over on patreon that's the
maximal episode
on the minimalist private podcast
patreon.com
the minimalist but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life
of the minimalist now last week our book
came out
and we couldn't go on tour with it like
we wanted to right away because there's
still certain
travel restrictions venue restrictions
bookstore restrictions
publisher restrictions a lot of rules
i hate rules me too except for our
minimalist rules
they're the only rules that matter so
we're going on tour but it's this fall
this winter we're going to 20 different
cities
us and canada hopefully overseas after
that but we'll see
right now it's called the love people
use things tour you can get your tickets
over at the minimalists.com
tour and by the way our audience gets
tickets
our patreon audience gets tickets 24
hours in advance so before anyone else
can then
our audience our regular audience can
get tickets and then
on friday they go on sale to the general
public so get your tickets before they
sell out some of these are some
smaller venues and so we're talking
three four or 500 people
we've done we've done 2 000 seaters in
the past right
and some of these are pretty small get
your tickets while you can
i would hate for you to pay a high price
these are really inexpensive tickets for
the types of venues that we're in but if
they all sell out then scalpers
take over and they start selling tickets
we're going to be in san antonio
houston dallas like we're going
everywhere around austin sorry about
that danny but
we're going to be three cities in texas
salt lake city denver phoenix orlando
atlanta nashville washington dc new york
boston toronto vancouver
seattle san francisco los angeles
columbus ohio
chicago illinois and minneapolis
minnesota that's 20 different cities
we're going to go to
the minimalists.com tour to get your
tickets before they are available
to the general public this friday
speaking of a lot of people use things
ryan we had
some bonuses before the book came out
some pre-order bonus we had a 90-page
digital companion workbook yeah so
anyone who pre-ordered the book so
if you pre-ordered the book you
submitted a receipt and now all of a
sudden you have this 90-page companion
workbook you can either it's digital or
you can print it out and there's a lot
of space for notes and
reflections questions to ask yourself as
well
and then we did this event with erwin
mcmanus and it's one of my favorite live
events we've ever done
it was great yeah we did it here in the
studio but you should have seen what
beulah did with the whole setup there's
actually two paintings over here that
you can't see
on youtube right now she painted these
pink paintings
which she was terrified to use pink
because it was some black white or beige
right right it wasn't part of her soul
apparently but she did an outstanding
job these abstract paintings
we had some balloons in here as well to
celebrate
the launch of the book and erwin was so
magnetic and amazing
and you missed the event i'm sorry but
there's an opportunity for
you to still see that event and to get
that digital workbook
if you head on over to the
minimalists.com virtual
and upload your receipt if you buy i
love people use things
before the end of january i'm going to
do this
the publisher might get mad and i'm
sorry but even if you check it out from
a library your local library
snap a photo of your library receipt
nice the minimalists.com
virtual upload your receipt right there
you'll get the 90 page digital workbook
for free
you'll get access to our live event for
free we want to pay us anything
and you'll get to enjoy love people use
things which
very well could be our best book yet
for added value this week ryan oh real
quick before even that
uh i'm going to before we go on tour
because we're going to do some reading
we're going to do live podcasts when we
do that tour
we're going to have special guests on
the tour we may even have some musical
guests on the tour that we're trying to
work out
so it's going to be uh sort of the
smorgasbord
of reading and talking and and live
podcasts and
and music etc all of these events that
we're going to have
i'm going to practice some reading on
clubhouse this month and next month i'm
not going to give you any dates right
now but if you follow me on
twitter just jfm on twitter
i will post the day of or if you follow
the minimalist on instagram
i'm sure we'll post the day of i'm going
to go live and just practice some
reading and
who knows ryan nicodemus might even join
me as well
for our added value segment this week
john mayer just had a brand new album
come out
it's called saab rock and i he was on
clubhouse
the day the album came out the night
that came out and bex and i
just sat down it was like gathering
around am radio
except it was clubhouse and he was
playing his album song by song and he
would give giving commentary in between
the songs
it was maybe 90 minutes of talk plus
music and it was really fascinating
because
the this album it takes on a different
meaning when you see the artwork and the
album cover it's very 80s it looks like
don hinley on the cover
but he's got these really deep profound
lyrics he has this one song
where he talks about um if you
you hurt me twice you're dead to me
if you hurt me three times your family
oh and that just cut man
why do we hurt the people we love the
most
quite often it's because we we love
things and we
use people we treat people as though
they're
objects anyway this song is called shot
in the dark it's his new single off the
new album
sabra another one of my favorite uh
lyrics
on the album it's from this song he said
i've loved seven other women and they
all were you mm-hmm
and now there was just something in that
right yeah we again it's there's an
objectification we all
are fallible in that way enjoy
shot in the dark from john mayer's new
album saab rock by the way
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like what are six important
questions to ask
before buying a new item what are the
minimalist favorite rules that they've
learned from their audience
how do you deal with people who don't
get it and continue to ignore your
pleas to stop giving you
stuff what is the dual purpose rule the
if i died today rule and the forget
about
it rule what is the container concept
and how might it help you avoid
overstuffing your home
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist if you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app we've got
simplified pricing over there so
we moved over to monthly pricing make it
easier for everyone so even if we put
out
a dozen private episodes this month you
don't get charged
anymore i will say this we have three
different tiers over there the vip tier
there's only as of this recording
there's four slots left so i hesitate
even mentioning it because they'll
be gone probably at least at least
within 24 hours of this recording coming
out
they will be gone we have only 200 of
the true
fan tiers left as well but if you become
a patreon supporter no matter what tier
you get access to
all of our archives and also the entire
community over there about 6
000 people who are not like-minded
but they are open-minded and so you can
engage with those folks
over on the community tab that's
patreon.com the minimalist if you come
to one of our
live podcast shows you can do that the
minimalists.com
tour follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist
writings for free if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com and if you leave here
today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye